good afternoon and welcome to blueprint
for efficiency a webinar speaker series
hosted by the Yale Center for business
in the environment my name is linh tran
and i will be your host for this
afternoon's presentation titled
harnessing energy embedded in water the
Yale Center for business in the
environment is pleased to present
blueprint for efficiency this series of
public webinars emphasizes the latest
opportunities for energy efficient
see through presentations that look at
corporate nonprofit and public private
developments blueprint explores energy
efficiency through the lenses of
behavior policy finance and technology
each presentation is recorded and
available on the blueprint for
efficiency website and the Yale
University iTunes channel please join us
next tuesday March 31st for secondary
markets in action q studies of
mobilizing capital for energy efficiency
we will discuss three secondary market
deals that have been executed in
different states and market segments in
today's webinar we will continue to
explore synergies and water and energy
management practices with our speakers
Amelia nuding and Gretchen Hardison
Amelia new ting is a water energy
analyst for Western resource advocates
she works with utilities municipalities
and state agencies to line water and
energy efficiency programs and improve
the integration of water and land use
planning she has worked in the
environmental sector for over a decade
and has also been a science teacher for
several years she has a master's and
water resources management from the bren
school at UC Santa Barbara and a
bachelor's in physics from Vassar
College Gretchen Hardin ssin is an
environmental affairs officer with the
Los Angeles Department of Water and
Power the municipal and electricity
electric utility
to be available as a member of this
efficiency solutions division Gretchen
overseas community partnership
activities including the partnership
with Southern California gas company for
joint customer incentive programs within
their shared territory prior to five
years with LED WP Gretchen managed the
air quality and climate change group at
this abuse Environmental Affairs
Department and worked as an
environmental consultant prior to that
Gretchen has a master's degree in urban
planning from UCLA and the bachelors in
social social ecology from UC Irvine
finally we would like to remind our
listeners that we welcome any questions
you might have and will direct as many
as we can to our speakers for today's
webinar will pause for questions in the
middle of the presentation and as well
as at the end of the presentation please
type questions directly into the go to
webinar chat window throughout the
presentation and with that we welcome
Amelia to blueprint for efficiency thank
you so much fun hi everyone good morning
and good afternoon depending on where
you're at my name is Amelia Newton and
today I'm going to be talking about
harnessing the energy embedded in water
when we talk about what the energy
embedded in water is typically we mean
it's the energy inputs that we use to
pump treat and heat water for drinking
and for wastewater treatment it's been
estimated that thirteen percent of total
energy use in the u.s. is related to
water services so it's a pretty
significant portion of our energy use
when you look at how this impacts
municipalities it typically is a pretty
significant portion of their total
energy costs
own and operate the water treatment
plants in a wastewater treatment plant
so what I'm interested in is not just
the energy inputs that we have and in
water but how can we get more energy
outputs from our water systems this is a
diagram of the basic water supply system
it comes from some source whether it's a
reservoir or from underground or
traveling across the land up in over a
mountain it gets pumped to the water
treatment facility and treated
distributed to customers that's the
bread and juice box and then eventually
goes on to waste water there may or may
not be some recycling going on it's
discharged and then becomes the source
for the next community downstream
assuming there is one we're going to
look at this in sort of three stages
looking at the energy efficiency
opportunities and energy generation
opportunities let's start off we're
going to start in the middle actually
that red box that says end use and
there's a good reason why heating water
that's the primary energy input at that
stage is the most energy intention
intensive stage of the water youth cycle
people often think of desalination as
the most energy intensive process
related to water because we all know
several desalination projects are not
viable economically because the energy
costs are so high but on a energy input
/ water unit per acre-foot or gallon
basis he
water at least 10 times as energy
intensive as desalination is so it's a
really important place to look at energy
savings and water savings
you
and if you're interested in how you can
make some efficiency improvements in
your own home you might like to know
that heating water typically accounts
for about twenty percent of your home
energy use so combining these energy and
water efficiency programs something that
I called conservation synergy this is a
smart thing to do we've got energy
utilities and both electric and gas and
water utilities implementing efficiency
programs but almost all the time these
programs are managed entirely separately
even though there's a lot of savings to
be realized between the two these
programs cannot only be implemented by
utility through a collaboration but they
can also be done by third-party programs
this image on the right here is an image
of a report that I did when I learned
about a few utilities who were working
together to integrate their energy and
water efficiency programs so I'm going
to walk you through a few of those
examples the first type of the utility
collaboration I was that was a joint
rebate so this is a rebate that's
offered by both Pacific Gas and Electric
and 41 water agencies that's because the
energy utilities distribution area
service area it's really large and
typically water agencies have a much
smaller distribution area within so in
order to cover the entire service area
for PG&E they had to work with this many
water agencies they got together and at
this point they have a hundred and fifty
dollar rebate for the highest efficiency
washing machine programs this program
has been in place for a few years at the
bottom of the screen there is a link to
their website and within the first
couple years of this program PG&E saw
sixty-three percent increase in
participation as compared with when they
ran this program by themselves it's
consistently been ranked highest in
customer satisfaction because their
customers are getting the benefit of a
one-stop shop they don't have to work
with several agencies and they have seen
lower administrative costs because of
the efficiencies of working together
type of utility collaboration is a joint
audit
audits are an extremely effective way to
achieve energy and water savings but
they're pretty expensive it requires a
lot of time from an expert who goes in
there and does you know very hands-on
work and looking at what are the
opportunities for more energy and water
savings well in Austin Texas the
municipal water utilities energy utility
and Texas gas service got together to
develop a try resource program
originally this was offered to
single-family residential homes and
after the success of that they decided
that it would make a lot of sense to try
to bring this to the multi-family
housing sector this is a typically
difficult sector to reach because of the
split incentive there's a person or an
entity who owns and operates the
building and then there's the renter's
so if you make efficiency upgrades that
cost is usually borne by the owner but
the benefits are seen by the bill
payer's the renter's but because these
three utilities got together and offered
a high value package they were able to
overcome that split incentive and had an
incredibly high rate of success and
willingness of multifamily housing
participation in about a year's time
they reached almost 2,000 multifamily
units and the way they organized it if
they had an auditor from Austin Energy
go into the various units and survey
everything that was going on he or she
would implement our sorry install
low-flow faucet heads aerators and
low-flow showerheads immediately and
also efficient light bulbs and then take
note of the other aspects of the
building and the units that might be
that might benefit from an efficiency
upgrade that report would then get sent
to each of the utilities they would
review and then contact the building
owner this has been a really popular
program they continue to work together
and may potentially expand this to the
commercial and industrial sector as well
type of collaboration is joint marketing
this is actually an example of a
collaboration that I helped to forge it
was between Xcel Energy which is the
largest electric and gas provider in
Colorado and six water utilities two of
them are the largest water utilities in
Colorado we when I went and spoke with
them I sort of casually mentioned the
idea of you know working with Excel or
working with the water utilities and now
it's really pleasantly surprised at how
eager all the utilities were to
participate some of them said you know
we've been thinking about doing this but
just never really happen didn't have the
time didn't know who to talk to so
they're really just needed someone to
bring them together so we got together
we SAT around a table and we reviewed
all the existing programs that were
going on and looked at some of the
near-term future ones and the utilities
decided that what made the most sense
was to embark on a joint marketing
campaign for an existing efficiency
program that's targeted at commercial
businesses with refrigerators this is a
very niche area and it's sort of a
difficult to reach sector because if
you're looking at your database of
customers it's hard to know which ones
have these commercial refrigerator's so
it's sell really benefited from the help
of just getting the word out and the
water utilities benefited because when
the staff person went into these
commercial businesses they would
automatically install pre rinse spray
novels and faucet aerators so together
we developed a few pieces of collateral
and about eight hundred Flyers were sent
out last year by the water utilities
that number to be sent out again this
year the last type of collaboration is
probably the biggest significant
collaboration in terms of the sheer
number of programs offered and it's
really interesting so I'm very pleased
to have Gretchen from ladwp talk about
her program Gretchen on to you
you
apologize for the technical
difficulties will be regression will be
on in just a minute Gretchen are you on
my apologies yes I don't forgive me I'll
do a quick introduction and thank you
Amelia I have forgotten to take myself
off mute it's pleasure to be here and
again my name is Gretchen Hardison and I
work in the efficiency solutions
division at dwp which houses both
electric energy efficiency and water
conservation programs I'm going to give
you a little firsthand perspective on
the topic of developing collaborations
between utilities so here as you can see
a little background on the utilities in
the city of Los Angeles as indicated in
our name LADWP as a department of the
city of Los Angeles or owned and
operated according to city charter and
city ordinances were the largest
municipal electric utility in the United
States serving about 4 million residents
we have in the neighborhood of 1.4
million electric meters and 680,000
water meters Southern California gas
company who we affectionately referred
to as SoCal gas is the local investor
owned natural gas utility that covers
much of southern california about twenty
percent of their gas meters are located
in the city of Los Angeles
to efficiency programs of iou's in
California operate under the oversight
of the California Public Utilities
Commission and publicly owned utilities
receive oversight from the California
Energy Commission so our regulatory
structures are distinct DWP in addition
operates under the authority of a
five-member board of commissioners with
oversight provided by the Los Angeles
City Council a mother a number of joint
individual programs between iou's often
at the direction of the Public Utilities
Commission iron use and POS don't
typically work together until now so a
few items here in the regulatory
framework here in California that help
set the stage for our partnership in
2005 we had state legislation and at
Bell 1037 that required p 0 use to make
energy efficiency a priority even though
many of us have been investing in energy
efficiency programs well before that
date a few years later the investor
owned utilities were directed by the PVC
to support local government efforts to
improve energy efficiency they having
the larger utilities having more
experience than most of the
municipalities in this area there's also
a lot of public interest in energy
efficiency in many organizations and
initiatives we're looking at energy
efficiency is one way one very good way
of reducing greenhouse gas emissions so
DWP and SoCalGas had tried to partner in
prior years on a few different programs
but they were always kind of one at a
time and we couldn't quite get through
the challenges that were posed by
partnering in one example DWP had
federal grant funds to put toward a
joint energy efficiency program but
SoCal gas was prevented from accepting
the federal funds because of the
reporting requirements and other strings
attached to that funding source but a
turning point coming came around in 2012
our board the mayor and city council
increased funding to the efficiency grew
up here at dwp and formally adopted a
goal of ten percent reduction and then
electricity used by 2020 which was
actually the goal the target that the
Energy Commission was expecting most
municipal utilities to come
by web but at that point energy
efficiency was written into our
integrated resource plan on the supply
side to help replace power from other
generation sources and by the way that
target of ten percent was increased the
last summer to fifteen percent reduction
by 2020 we had a new general manager and
other conditions here were really ripe
for a new approach to energy efficiency
and SoCal gas was thrilled that we were
finally ready and able to partner in a
large way with our neighbouring with our
sister utility so as we chat and
discussed options for partnering we
identified some common goals and values
that we could achieve and partnering
namely achieving our respective energy
efficiency goals which as you all know
it becomes a little more difficult as we
go through that low hanging fruit and to
better serve our joint territory
customers so we developed in a
relatively short period of time about
six months our teams put together a
master inter utility agreement for
energy and water efficiency and resource
savings so behind the scenes there were
multiple drafts lots of phone calls
meetings with our attorneys redraft
running up and down stairs trying to get
people to listen but because we had
willing partners in the two utilities
and we had strong support from our
executive management on both sides we
were able to put together an agreement
that both utilities could live with
again the goal was to share costs while
delivering try resource programs within
our joint service area and to allow a
high degree of flexibility to create new
programs and modifying existing programs
as needed contracting is really very
difficult for dwp and we really wanted
to make sure this one was going to serve
our needs I'm going to talk more about
the process on the next slide but here's
a little snapshot of our current status
we celebrated our two year anniversary
of our partnership in September and we
also renewed Xena
interview tility agreement for three
more years through the end of 2017 and
we expect to extend that again for at
least twenty twenty and hopefully well
beyond that we have launched eleven
joint programs to date and we have three
or four more on deck to come online in
the next couple of months early on we
held a joint training for the account
managers from each of our organizations
so they could become more familiar with
the joint programs we were doing but
also become more familiar with the solo
programs of the partner utility one of
the things we've had to do is to teach
ourselves and really learn to get in the
habit of referring our customers to our
partner utility when our utility doesn't
have a program to support the particular
customer review and I'm going to jump to
the next slide to discuss these last
couple bullets which is a simple diagram
of how the master inner utility
agreement work the mi ua provides the
structure of the agreement in this
document which was approved by our board
we have the purpose of the partnership
the general terms and conditions the
length of the agreement any termination
clauses and how we're dealing with
confidentiality of customer information
and data this really is our high-level
document sort of our contract although
we don't call it a contract from which
we cheer program orders the program
orders are similar to a task order
vendor contract and again they tear from
the master agreement and this level of
document can be approved by management
and both utilities and that was written
into the master agreement the program
order describes one joint program it
identifies the lead utility the program
managers the roles and responsibilities
of each utility it describes how the
program runs how we all coordinate
together the program budget the cost
share between the two utilities and how
the lead utility will invoice the
partner utility the structure provides
us with a lot of flexibility once our
teams agree on the concept of a joint
program we can usually put it together
you know in about eight weeks there are
some programs that have taken several
months because we have to navigate our
either our different regulatory
structures or our financial structures
or some element of how we roll out our
work programs but for the most part
they're pretty easy to get going the
joint programs are generally an expanded
version of an ongoing program the lead
utility will have a program that would
benefit from partnering with our other
utility sometimes for example natural
gas programs benefit from including
electric measures to attract more
customer interest and that have the
promise of higher incentives for
customers for dwp partnering with SoCal
gas has allowed us to offer our
customers in the city of Los Angeles a
number of statewide program so we're not
previously available here so this brings
more consistency for the local
contractor community who works across
jurisdictions within the region I here
we've displayed our current 11 joint
programs many of these again are
statewide programs that are offered in
the investor-owned utility territories
under the direction of the California
Public Utilities Commission they include
joint incentives for new construction
both residential and commercial number
of direct install programs where we work
crews will go out and install measures
that are free to the customer and we
also jointly support the work of the Los
Angeles Better Buildings challenge team
and we have been equal DWP has been able
to participate in statewide
organizations and groups dedicated to
advancing codes and standards here in
California and looking at emerging
technologies statewide we're working to
launch a few more programs soon as I
mentioned earlier the energy savings
assistance program which is a direct
install program for low-income residents
we hope to get off the ground and work
with our City Housing Authority in the
next couple of months we're also looking
at a program to fund energy and water
efficiency training for building
operators as well as new curriculum in
our local school district and we're
looking at the food service industry as
a particular point where we can provide
joint incentives to take advantage of
natural gas electric and water savings
there again some of the points that we
tried
in mind as we're looking at new
potential programs is how can we better
serve our customers through a single
point of contract where can we achieve
water savings with ongoing gas programs
where can we achieve electric and gas
program savings together again DWP is
very fond of the joint progress because
they really allow us to expand our reach
impacting more customers generating more
savings toward meeting our goals with
minimal impact on our staff Jeff company
has been very gracious in bringing us in
to some of their ongoing programs and
expanding those to the city of Los
Angeles or extending them through
including electric measures which again
can sometimes attract more customers to
the programs and the partnership has
really raised both the profile of DWP at
the state level and for are now
beginning to participate in discussions
with the investor owned utilities and
SoCal gas i would note also has derived
the number of benefits from working
seriously and at length with the
municipal utility a few highlights from
the partnership that make this
successful really very important
top-down support from executives of both
utilities has really made this happen
staff level we keep it going but the
commitment from the top really got have
started it's important to be open to new
opportunities and we are learning to be
aware of the restrictions of rolling out
programs with our partner utility in
terms of marketing we have agreed to
always feature both logos on promotional
materials for the joint programs we've
gone on to held a joint events for our
staff we had a couple of joint Earth Day
celebrations and some other events as
for benefits for our customers we see
increasing incentives and really again
the expansion of statewide programs into
the city of Los Angeles territory that
were not previously available I'll also
note that the partnership with DWP has
really served as a model for some
California gas to partner with other
municipalities in their territory kind
of work through the kinks with them and
they have rolled out and now have part
ships with the public electric utilities
in the City of Riverside Anaheim they're
coming online with Pasadena and they
have a new partnership with the
Metropolitan Water District obviously
not unelected programs but on water
programs so to wrap up i'm just showing
a little snapshot here of some of the
measures of success on this current
round of programs the new construction
programs again our statewide programs
that have been available outside LA and
are now available with looking at the
three resources natural gas water and
electricity for residential and
commercial and we have a multi-family
direct install similar to one of these
mentioned earlier where third-party
contractors will come in and just switch
out faucet aerators and showerheads and
we've been able to save millions of
gallons of water and hundreds of
thousands of therms energy upgrade
California reaches our single-family
residence at this point we hope to
expand that to include multifamily
residents later this year and again
we're partnering on with the Better
Buildings challenge because standards
enriching technologies thank you for
your time and I'd be happy to answer any
questions and so we have a question from
David for Gretchen does ladwp provide
financing options for their customers to
implement the recommended measures we
have only one true financing program in
house which is an infrastructure loan
program we are looking in fact met with
socalgas just a couple of days ago to
look at financing pilot programs that
are very keen on line here in California
later this year hopefully we have not
been able to host a non bill repayment
or on bill financing at this point in
time is some constraints we have with
our customer billing system but we are
actively looking with subcon gas to see
how we might be able to partner and
financing and we do have an active base
property assessed clean energy financing
program here in the county of los
angeles which all of our customers have
access to great thanks Gretchen and we
have a second question from Jonathan for
Amelia can you please explain how higher
value packages overcome both the split
incentive good question I think it's
because so when you think about what the
building owner pays for sometimes they
pay directly for the water if those
units were not sub metered but the
energy one if it's the energy efficiency
installments was those benefits would
accrue to the renter's so by combining
all three the
the renter's receive a benefit and the
owners receive a benefit it's also
possible that with the gas inventory
that the how much is made in court that
any efficiency installments there those
benefits would accrue to the owner so
all that combined the owner does see
benefits and then there's also sort of
the long term possibility that the owner
can advertise those rental units as more
efficient which would likely be
appealing to renters
great thanks so much Amelia I'm going to
turn it over to you to finish the rest
of our presentation and will continue to
do qaid once you conclude to wrap up the
webinar okay great so just to wrap up
this portion of the webinar about in
turn utility collaborations I wanted to
highlight to use some of the benefits
that were identified by collaborators so
this list is not meant to indicate that
all of these benefits will be realized
in any given partnership rather than
sort of the laundry list of folks
experiences so several utilities found
that they had higher participation rates
and that was in part tribute afull to
broader promotional strategies PG&E
worked a lot with the water utilities to
get the word out in retail stores where
these washing machines are sold to
really get the word out to customers
with all of that quote about manpower
they were able to get the word out more
effectively some utilities solve lower
costs through shared administrative
processes and in general almost all the
utilities reported increased customer
satisfaction they have a one-stop shop
experience rather than having to work
with three different utilities or two
and customers see their utilities of
working smarter and not harder they also
benefit from coordinated and
complementary program design I have
actually seen an mg utility and a water
utility for both offering showerheads we
were slightly different models and they
were effectively competing with each
other because they have slightly
different processes for how they were
distributed but really we don't want any
competition and hate programs that's one
of the good reasons to work together and
then it paved the way for long term
collaborative opportunities which I
think has been shown very well with LED
WP
SoCalGas but of course it's not only
busy right arm there is a significant
upfront time investment there's no way
around that once the partnership is well
under way you sort of created the
pathways that will enable easier
partnerships down the line but at first
it's going to take a while you've got to
get folks from your finance and
marketing and you know efficiency
program operation is all on the same
page you're essentially establishing new
prophecies in the report I talked about
I provide sort of a guideline for the
collaborative process that just sort of
highlights some of these think to watch
out for and ways to overcome these
barriers there are also differences in
service territory as I showed you a PG&E
typically an energy utility would have
to work with a lot of water utilities
and that can be challenging and daunting
and perhaps a barrier there are
certainly differences between the way in
which water utilities operates their
efficiency programs and energy utilities
operate particularly if that energy
utilities regulated by a public utility
permission they are used to a pretty
expensive process and rigorous analysis
whereas those that don't have don't have
to have that level of regulatory
oversight can have really different ways
of running their efficiency programs so
that can lead to differences in data
collection protocol and expectations
it's really important to sort of hammer
out those expectations early on one of
the ways that you can do that is by
establishing memorandum of understanding
or interview tility agreement that can
help to establish the trust that's
needed Trust was a big issue that came
up for a lot of utilities I spoke with
it just didn't know who exactly they
were working with until the time to pass
and their partnership that evolves
unless unfortunately regulatory bodies
can be a barrier about in California
they really helped to pave the way for
several utilities to collaborate but I
can tell you from my experience with
xcel energy and water utilities in
Colorado there were some challenges with
sharing data and that ultimately came
down to a regulatory issues so it's
important to be clear on how each
participating utility is regulated and
what standards they need to adhere to
to this diagram because as you recall we
were talking about for that center piece
where I put water use now we're going to
sort of take a step back and look at the
whole water supply cycle and look at
where their opportunity efficiency and
energy generation and I want to take
this step back and take a broader look
at how we think about water management
because I think it's high time that we
view water management a little
differently not just as water it
management water energy and even
municipal waste management that's why
this slide is entitled a new paradigm
perhaps a bit lossy but we need this
different sort of thinking to chart a
different future as we move forward so
one small difference in this chart
compared to the first one that it showed
is a redbox the first time around that
was called ed use that is the most
common term used to describe the
customers for receiving the water but I
want to change that term I don't want to
call it end use one there's the obvious
fact that it's clearly not at the end
right in the middle of a cycle that
actually repeat but I'm not just trying
to be a you know cutie here there's a
good reason for removing that word which
is because NGS is the wrong way to think
about it if that is the end goal of the
water supply system then you're really
sort of focusing everything on those
customers but there's so much energy
embedded in the other stages of the
water supply cycle but let's just call
those water users and look at all the
opportunities that exist throughout this
process for energy generation
so first we'll look at water conveyance
and distribution there are a lot of
opportunities to install small hydro
turbines in pipes and ditches ever water
is flowing we can harness the kinetic
energy of this water as it's moving and
getting punch whenever there's a you
know right level of head for it in
addition sometimes utilities need to
reduce the pressure of the water that
they are delivering to their customers
because it has to be within a certain
range to provide regular water service
in a home or business it's often times
the pressure reducing valve is used but
you can actually sometimes be replaced
by hydropower turbines where you're
going to be generating energy at the
same time now any decision to do this is
of course going to depend on the
engineering and the specifications of
the particular place and i'll also say
this is not new technology this has been
done for quite some time but the
American Society of Civil Engineers
estimates that more than one trillion
dollars in system repairs is needed in
the drinking water systems and 300
billion in wastewater treatment systems
so if we're thinking a little bit bigger
about our water system as more than just
a water but also an energy system the
question is can we make some of those
necessary investments pay off how can we
do it differently this next time there's
some really interesting advancements in
technology that were brought to my
attention by dr. Talos Arab amor d he is
a Dean of the Patel College of global
studies at the University of South
Florida and it's done a lot of thinking
about the next generation of water
supply systems so there are what are
called smart pipes that have fiber optic
sensors embedded in them that can send a
signal when there's a change in strain
or temperature in the pipe and alert the
operation folks that likely there's
maybe been from leak or some you know
disturbance in the system right now with
our typical steel pipes underground we
have no idea that there's a leak until a
problem occurs unless there's something
catastrophic water main break above
ground there's also a fairly new
technology called self-healing type
and this technology was modeled after
the way that our own bodies heal when we
have a cut just in the way that
platelets will help to form a scab and
heal a wound there are polymers that are
sent down a pipe and ultimately still in
the breach or the you know break in the
pipe fill it and feel it this is being
used not only in water pipes but also an
oil and gas pipes or grease oil pipes
unlikely their advances in reducing the
friction in a pipe friction is a major
retarding force in terms of transporting
water along and so the more we can
reduce the friction less energy we'd
have to use to be able to pump it to
move it along
we spent a fair amount of time already
talking about the way that energy and
water utilities can work together to
integrate their
efficiency programs at the water use
stage
cycle but there's one more technology i
wanted to let you know about
if you think about it we heat our water
and I already told you how energy
intensive that is a music momentarily
while we're watching our hands or
showering or doing our clothes and then
it flows out of the house onto the
wastewater treatment plant or septic
system but much of that heat at that
point just sort of gets wasted along the
way there is a way to capture that heat
through a heat exchanger adds the warm
water leaving your house that heat
exchanger can take the heat from that
warm water and transfer it to cold water
that's going into a water heater it can
keep water from 20 to 30 degrees using
this technology and while the cops Barry
on there are at least a few companies
who are offering these and installing
these in homes it can be there done on
existing home or of course more easily
in a new home when you get to design all
of the engineering yourself from the
outset but the payback can have a period
of roughly five years or more
and lastly is the wastewater portion and
this is another term that I would like
to change there is so much energy
embedded in wastewater kinetic thermal
and chemical energy that I think it's a
crime almost to call it wastewater we
need to start learning resource water or
some other terms that indicates how much
value it has now I'm not going to walk
you through the whole wastewater
treatment process but i do want to draw
your attention in this diagram to the
top right portion we see those two bread
bowls says power generation and it's
connected to a digester this digester
takes organic solids that are taken from
the wastewater and microbes digest them
and I vertically without the presence of
oxygen as a result methane and carbon
dioxide are produced and that biogas can
be used to spend a turbine and generate
electricity it can also be used directly
for operations on the plants that
require gas the water Environment
Research Foundation has done a lot of
work and research looking at how much
energy is embedded in wastewater they
found that in the largest wastewater
treatment plant it contains ten times as
much energy as needed for treatment of
that water if we can effectively harness
it we could not only turn these
wastewater treatment plants into water
treaters but energy generators as a
small power plant so again this is a big
idea requires there's a lot of details
and engineering and of course money
that's required to get this done but if
we look ahead and we know that all of
our systems require significant
investment how can we make those
investments smarter than we have in the
past now that we have so much more
knowledge about how to generate that
energy well there are a few leaving out
which water utilities that are already
starting to think about this I want to
give you a couple of cape study examples
first
a wastewater treatment plants in New
York with Albany New York it's
relatively small not a huge plant but in
the 90s they found themselves over sized
for the amount of which water that they
were treating so their first step was to
become extremely energy-efficient they
needed to reduce their operating costs
they did have a bio digester on site so
they actually helped court any gilbert
company to locate their facilities
nearby so that they could take their
yogurt weights and digest those in the
digesters foods and and very types of
waste are tremendously potent producers
of biogas most yogurt company is
actually sy a si GE the Greek yogurt
company and they have very delicious
yogurt you've ever had some so through
all of this the efficiency upgrades and
capturing that yogurt ways they saw a
huge change in their energy profile over
time this is a diagram of their energy
usage from 94 to 2011 the green bar
represents the electricity they are
producing on site and the yellow bar is
the electricity that they were
purchasing from the utility obviously
see a dramatic rise in 2011 that was the
result of additional bio digester
efficiencies and installment that they
need but you can see that green was sort
of increasing over time as they were
processing that yogurt waste in addition
the exception of 2011 their overall
energy use profile the total trended
downward as a result of the energy
efficiencies they implemented this
wastewater treatment is approaching Net
Zero they currently can't net meter and
so and by electricity to the grid but
they are about you know ninety
ninety-five percent the way there
another interesting case study is East
Bay mud in California there a huge waste
water treatment plant and they've been
invested in on-site energy generation
for decades they are currently actually
a net
energy producer they are producing more
energy on site annually than they use in
a year they do still buy electricity
from the grid because at any given
moment they may not be producing as much
energy as they need but over the course
of the year they are allowed to net
meter and so they are net energy
generator one of the things that really
brought them to the next this next level
was an innovative program that they
developed of collecting food scraps from
commercial industries and industrial
food operations we absque wraps up as I
mentioned are extremely potent and
produced three times as much methane as
municipal wastewater solids when they're
digested and bio digester so by using
this they're not only becoming an energy
producer but they are addressing
municipal waste management food waste is
a huge contributor to our landfills and
there's a huge contributor to methane
when it just decomposes in the landfills
so this is a major asset to the local
municipal waste managers as well so by
thinking this much larger these water
operators can be much more than just
thinking about water and what are
quality but they're thinking about
energy generation and municipal waste
management's
there's opportunity to increase the
amount of energy we generate at
wastewater treatment plants this is an
image that shows how many bio digesters
are located and which water treatment
plants not only about ten percent of
which water treatment plants have bio
digesters that number of that number is
the 12 38 that you see but of those bio
digesters that exist that wastewater
treatment plants only about twenty-five
percent of them are generating
electricity the vast majority are
flaring that gas and not using it to
benefit so there really is tremendous
opportunity you know when we're to sort
of thinking vague about how to do more
with what we already have and of course
as we our population growth and we need
to expand our facilities or possibly
even build new wastewater treatment
plants these are ideas that we should be
keeping in mind so I think the whole
point here is that when you start to
think a little bit bigger about our
future and where are our water industry
is headed we need to look to these early
adopters like the utilities who are
working together on their efficiency
programs like the wastewater utilities
who are not only energy generators but
municipal solid waste managers this is
the new paradigm for water management
this integration making use of all of
these resources together that concludes
my presentation and as my contact
information and there's a link to the
report if you're interested in checking
it out and we will open it up for
questions for Gretchen and myself
great the first question we have is from
Patrick how are the electric saving is
being calculated for Austin and ladwp
are the savings tied to water delivery
and treatment
I'll let Gretchen go first
well depending on the program we do
calculate energy savings based on the
new measures to be installed compared
with the prior electric usage i'm not
sure i'm totally following the question
for some programs savings are deemed if
we're installing lighting for example we
do now i take that back we calculate the
savings based on the number of hours of
operation and the wattage and things of
the prior lighting in austin i'm pretty
sure that the energy savings are
calculated are just for the efficiency
measures that are directly installed in
the building's I if I correct an
understanding the question I think it's
asking sort of our the upstream energy
savings is the embedded energy and water
counted and I if I understand correctly
I'm not sure I do to my knowledge it's
not corrected cups are calculated in the
figures that I reported on but that is
something that they they care about and
we Twp has just started working with a
team at UC Davis under professor Frank
Lodge to look at the embedded energy in
our water treatment and distribution
system and our wastewater excuse me
system here in the city and as we get
closer to learning more about where
those empty inputs actually occur
throughout the system will be looking at
ways to make those more efficient but
currently as a million said we do not
calculate our counting any savings from
from that thank you both we'll move on
to the next question from Sid you talked
about capturing waste energy from waste
and from drain pipes there's also a lot
of energy loss through chimneys and flus
is there any way to address this wasted
energy through any of your programs our
technologies that capture waste heat
influence and chimney is part of the
efficiency program well I have to admit
that's not something I know a lot about
and I haven't seen much about so there
may be opportunities to capture some of
that those heat losses but
I'm sorry I don't know enough about that
and certainly in some of the food
forgive me of in the energy upgrade
California programs home upgrade
programs where contractors are looking
at building envelope heat losses are
modeled and identified I'm not familiar
with any specific strategies to reduce
heat loss from Jimmy's and flus but that
is something that should be identified
in an extensive audit of a residential
or commercial facility and certainly on
the more comprehensive home upgrade
programs thanks our next question is
from Jonathan how will L LADWP be
promoting the upcoming launch of the
residential page program which will be
available to all LA City owners and
countries and county wide thank you well
we are going to be working with the
county as they identify the providers
who will be offering the residential
pace program here we have a number of
local nonprofit organizations that we
work with through a grant program to
provide energy efficiency information
and outreach to our communities across
the city will certainly be advertising
that on our website and have links to
the pace providers we work to with the
Los Angeles Better Buildings challenge
which is currently supporting the
commercial pace program we help fund
their efforts here and try to coordinate
on outreach we Twp has an electronic
newsletter that we send out to our
residential customers who will obviously
be featuring it in that channel as well
Thank You Gretchen and we have a
question from Peter beyond energy
savings incentives what other
value-added motivations are used to
encourage measures and this is both to
Amelia and Gretchen I'm sorry to repeat
that
sure no problem beyond energy savings
incentives what other value-added
motivations are used to encourage
measures
you want to start a million yeah I'm not
sure if I fully understand the question
the benefits I suppose there's benefits
to the utilities and the customers do
you think that we're talking about
customers here yes we're speaking about
customers okay well typically customers
have been really happy with the joint
utility programs because it's much
easier and they see larger savings they
get through this one stop shop
experience and in the case of the rebate
they're getting a right now they're
getting $150 rebate as a compared to a
fifty-dollar rebate when PG&E was
operating that rebate alone so really
just the increased savings and increased
ease of achieving those savings um have
been a major benefit to the customers
I would agree hopefully they are
realizing increased comfort in their
homes and offices once they have more
appropriate lighting and heating and
ventilation measures installed but
certainly a single point of contact
greater incentive dollars and certainly
the utilities realize greater energy
savings okay great thank you we have a
couple more questions and so the first
set of questions is do contractors need
additional
july's training to know how to properly
install drain water heat recovery system
if yes how do they get that training and
are there leading manufacturers of such
systems that provide training that's a
good question I so I when I was looking
into this I looked at a youtube video
and was convinced that I'm not skilled
enough to do it but someone who's pretty
handy could make it a suit like I
do-it-yourself type of project that's it
i'm sure some training in this would be
extremely helpful I know if one company
in particular who installs these systems
it's called Nexus e water as to whether
they provide training I'm not sure about
the training programs out there
unfortunately but they might be a good
first place to check as I'm sure they
would know about who does those
trainings if they don't offer that
themselves
great thank you our next question is
from amy is there a third party
verification process for East Bay mud
and the river village Johnson joint
wastewater treatment facility for their
net positive in ninety percent energy
reduce claims and is there any
certification or recognition process for
them that's a great question to my
knowledge of there has not been an
official third-party certifier there was
a pretty extensive paper developed and
submitted to the EPA about East Bay mud
and the EPA also provides a benchmark
energy use with a benchmark for energy
use at wastewater treatment plants so I
most of that is self-reported but you
know when you go on to that site you can
sort of see if you are wastewater
treatment plant is average for your size
and specs or using more or less I think
a third-party verifier might be
something that happens in the future if
it becomes a more significant trend my
sense that there's really only a few
utilities in the u.s. that do this it's
a bit more popular and prevalence in
Europe actually so find several more
case studies over there if we can take
some lessons from there that would help
I will also add that though
water Environment Research Foundation
has been working on a project where
they're converting I think 25 wastewater
utility plans to try to make them net
energy zero or net generating so that
report should be coming out hopefully
within this year I think and that will
not only help identify sort of what are
going prophecies and challenges with
that conversions or existing plans but
also I suppose X as something of a
third-party verifier and so they're an
independent research organization
Thank You Amelia and we'll go with one
last question how does LADWP replace
revenue / from reduced consumption leave
me with the easy question at the end oh
well I don't know that I have enough
detail to give you a really solid answer
on that we are pretty cut well just
about midpoint through our twenty ten to
twenty twenty excuse me time frame that
we're trying to reach our efficiency
goals but if you'd like to contact me
afterwards I've been happy to get a
response for you on that and that
concludes today's talk on harnessing
energy embedded in water I'd like to
thank both Amelia and Gretchen for
joining us this afternoon if you'd like
to view or share recording of today's
webinar please visit the blueprint for
efficiency website and remember that all
blueprint for efficient news well
webinars are also posted on iTunes you
make sure to tune in next Tuesday march
three first for our webinar highlighting
key studies the secondary market
transactions for energy efficiency this
webinar will feature speakers from the
connecticut greenbank the Delawares
sustainable energy utility oversight
board Kraft 3 and self-help credit union
join us to understand lessons learned
from these through real-world deals this
is landon transform video center for
business in the environment saying so
long from New Haven Connecticut